so why did i get suspended the day after
we declared our independence ironically
this happened at 3 a.m last night so
just after
july 4th these twitter freaks what did
they do well here's the image this is
the email i woke up to this morning
i have violated their rules against
hateful conduct and what are those rules
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race
ethnicity national origin sexual
orientation
gender gender identity religious
affiliation age disability or serious
disease now
that doesn't sound like something that
dave rubin would do i poke fun at people
i make fun of people but i certainly
don't instigate violence or really go
after people for their immutable
characteristics so what is it that i
tweeted i must have done something so
horrific and so out of character that
would have brought upon this this just
damning condemnation of what i am and
what i do what was my tweet
uh the tweet was uh this the insanity
continues at twitter jordan peterson has
been suspended for this tweet about
ellen page he just told me he will never
delete the tweet paging elon musk and
what i did there was screenshot jordan's
jordan peterson's tweet about ellen page
now ellen page
was an actress who i suppose is now an
actor named elliot page you may remember
i don't know of any work that elliott
page has done am i missing any big
movies that elliot page has done but
ellen page used to be an x-men and she
was pretty good she she i think i can
say ellen page was in x-men and she was
pretty good she was a she at the time
anyway all i did was screenshot
and comment on jordan being suspended
now ironically here's where this is why
this is all
sort of so mangled in the way they do
everything this tweet that i sent this
defense of jordan was from a week ago
because he got suspended about a week
ago you may remember we talked about it
on the show and jordan
put up a pretty spectacular video on his
youtube channel explaining why he will
not
delete that tweet um so what's
interesting here is about a week ago i
post that now all week long i was
getting warnings from twitter that i had
uh been reported to the german
authorities and all sorts of stuff so
the the trans activists the woke
wackadoodles they were mass uh reporting
my account trying to get me suspended
and i and then suddenly at 3 a.m right
after july 4th suddenly i get suspended
i did issue a a statement on locals
because i do have an ability to get my
message out even if i am not on twitter
so i want to read my statement to you
and then i want to give some props to
some of the people that are defending me
right now here's my
uh response this is my official
statement this is dave rubin reading
dave rubin's official statement about
his twitter suspension i have been
suspended by twitter for posting a
screenshot of jordan peterson's tweet
tweet which got he himself suspended
while it is unclear how i broke their
terms of service it is clear that they
are breaking their fiduciary
responsibility to their shareholders by
letting a bunch of woke activists run
the company i hope elon musk's purchase
of twitter goes through so he can blow
up their servers and humanity can move
past this pervasive twisted self-imposed
mental institution in the meantime you
can find me at
rubinreport.locals.com the platform i
created to fight big tech censorship
something we need now more than ever let
me give some props publicly to a few of
the people defending me because you know
one of the things and this is maybe the
real bumper sticker of all of this it's
not about ellen page or elliot page and
it's not about misgendering someone and
or anything like that what this is
really about is how fear spreads right
because if you say something that's true
but then you know that facebook or
instagram or twitter can take you out
for it uh you might be less willing to
say something true right if you get
suspended once then maybe the second
time you're gonna be like ah i'm just
not gonna say the true thing so what
happens is when they suspend jordan
peterson
only a for saying something true only a
certain amount of people are willing to
say oh i'll defend him i'll post the
screenshot i'll say he shouldn't be
suspended because they don't want to get
suspended right so i think it is worthy
of crediting some of the people uh who
are defending me right now because
you're not just you're not defending me
i don't mean to make this about me what
you're defending is the ability for
truth to be said you know in the public
square as we have it in 2022. so ben
shapiro who's been nothing but an
all-star in this fight against this woke
nonsense he says reuben report has now
been suspended for posting news about
jordan peterson's suspension all because
we are not allowed to mention that until
five minutes ago elliot paige who is
very very very male was a female actress
named ellen page here's dave's statement
a couple other people real quick on this
uh who else we have there tim poole holy
[ __ ] reuben report was suspended for
uh posting about jordan peterson getting
suspended how did he even break any
rules uh and then douglas murray who is
just the perfect british author so ruben
report has been suspended from twitter
for commenting on jordan peterson being
suspended from twitter does twitter
intend to have a future also could it
could it explain whether elliott was
ever ellen
or caitlin was ever
bruce and then jack besobiak also
reuben report has been suspended from
twitter for defending jordan peterson
and a whole bunch of my my florida
freedom fighters josh hammer carol
markowitz uh john cardillo david boy all
jumped in on it many other people anyway
again i don't mean to make this about me
i don't really even mean to make this
about
elliot page or ellen page or any of that
it is the new thing that you cannot say
you cannot say something true there are
biological differences between males and
females if you dead name someone i would
not i honestly would not even and i
don't even want to say this because i
don't want to play by their rules but i
would not know how to refer to who did
she play in uh x-men
she was uh
who is she and x-men ellen page and
x-men was a good character i like those
movies i liked all those x-men movies
they're jumping back and forth between
time who did she play what was the name
of the character whoever it was the
point is that how would i refer to her
as oh i liked that character right i
liked that character kitty
was her name but who is the they they
she had a name like an x-man name
shadow what
shadow girl
shadow cat
ellen page was shadowcat anyway doesn't
matter the point is i like the x-men
movies i thought she was good in them
but now do i have to say oh elliot page
was a woman named ellen page and played
a woman named kitty pride in x-men but
i'm not a biologist so are they even
x-men
also [ __ ] stupid bunch of morons
anyway jordan peterson has said he will
not delete his tweet regarding this
whole incident uh and i have to decide
what i want to do you know i'm all about
building new things i'm all i would love
to cause these things to now implode
from the inside these companies don't
deserve our attention they're
manipulating us in crazy ways perhaps we
all should have risen up
uh more so when they when they took out
donald trump and when they took out a
whole bunch of other people
when they hid the hunter biden story
think of the way they are manipulating
us in crazy ways guys